ils l'ont baptisé le mur du climat dans
lequel selon eux le monde fonce tout
droit et ils sont venus le dire par
milliers ces militants sont opposés à
l'autoroute a69 dont le tracé va
recouvrir 400 hectares de terres
agricoles 200 arbres centenaires seront
abattus
arbres au centenaires ou plus riches en
tonnerre plus des forêts entières qui
vont être abattues donc c'est des
milliers d'arbres qui ont été abattu en
réalité 200 arbres seront abattus et le
double planté en compensation le projet
touche également une vingtaine
d'hectares de zones humides 55 hectares
seront recréés et végétalisés c'est
formidable parce que en France dès que
tu veux construire l'autoroute un stade
de football un parking etc ce n'est plus
possible maintenant c'est 15 ans c'est
15 ans de travaux c'est-à-dire que il y
a quoi qu'il arrive quelqu'un qui va
découvrir que il y avait une espèce
d'abeille ou de de je ne sais quoi qu'il
fallait protéger et non mais c'est vrai
c'est une manière de résumer là ou alors
chaque GPT aurait mieux fait là
l'autoroute de 53 km permettra de relier
quatre à Toulouse en moins d'une heure
contre une heure 15 actuellement via la
route nationale 126 un gain de temps
appréciable pour les travailleurs mais
du côté des élus d'opposition on y voit
aucun intérêt on est dans un
anéantissement de la biodiversité un
anéantissement Sandrine Rousseau
Sandrine
est-ce qu'il y a un seul homme au monde
que vous admirez
à mon avis Tony Parker
ça vous fait rire
un camusien pourrait dire c'est normal
que les gilets jaunes trouvent chaque
semaine l'énergie de se réunir et de
coaliser des opinions disparates en
revanche quand il s'agit de présenter un
projet il y a plus que Francis Lalanne
il a bien
[Applaudissements]
donc l'argumentation
la population mondiale dirigée par un
gouvernement autocratique est passé de
la moitié de l'humanité en 2011 à 70% en
2021 c'est plus de 5 millions de
personnes milliards de personnes pardon
c'est plus d'un quart des habitants de
la planète qui vit dans un régime qui
est complètement fermé vous vous dites
j'adore notre époque oui parce que oui
oui d'abord parce que je suis vivant
c'est très important je suis vivant dans
cette époque et que et que les
années que je base
au profiter d'une époque voilà et et
surtout que ce qui est fait était
magnifique ce qui va se faire j'en sais
rien mais aujourd'hui c'est parfait
peut-être que l'erreur a été de ne pas
être assez présent pour porter cette
réforme moi-même la phrase du jour est
signée manuel Macron lors d'un échange
avec les lecteurs du Parisien apparaître
demain le président reconnaît même je
cite qu'il aurait dû se mouiller
davantage pour défendre la réforme des
retraites la France me fait de la peine
en ce moment vraiment vraiment la France
me fait de la peine parce que je trouve
que le niveau du débat politique est
absolument affligent je conçois très
très bien qu'on soit contre ce projet de
réforme des retraites absolument
moi-même j'aurais préféré de loin que le
premier projet de réforme des retraites
soit adopté plutôt que celui-là
Laurent Berger vous allez prendre votre
retraite en juin à 54 ans est-ce que ce
n'est pas un peu tôt
moi honnêtement on est dimanche soir je
vais rentrer je vais retrouver mes
quatre enfants et je vais chercher le
film de ce type là ça pourrait être les
tuches ça pourrait être osser familial
parce que j'adore ça la scène des doigts
berbères ça confine au génie en plus
elle est improvisée quand on lui
discrive c'est une bonne scission
écoutez il y a pas de bonne ou de
mauvaises situations c'est génial un
média check écrit Emmanuel Macron est
devenu l'homme d'État le plus dangereux
d'Europe après Vladimir Poutine
carrément pourquoi est-ce qu'on entend
tous les jours que le fascisme montrait
en France mais enfin qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire que aller dans des pays où le
fascisme monte ou bien le fascisme est
monté enfin c'est top scène de dire des
choses comme ça le niveau de haine de
haine personnelle contre le président de
la République m'afflige quand on réagit
physiquement devient violent c'est pour
eux c'est de la violence
mais il y a la violence des mots il y a
la violence du mépris tu ne violence
c'est à dire que le terrorisme
économique une forme de dictature j'ai
tendance à penser que l'autorité de
l'État elle est aussi garantie par
quelqu'un qui tient parole et qui ne se
laisse pas dicter son chemin par les
aléas de l'opinion c'est aussi une
affaire d'autorité ça l'autorité elle
est aussi là moi j'adorais que le
gouvernement voilà mettre ses coups sur
la table et disent ok on va écouter les
syndicalistes et on va trouver une
réponse c'est pas le cas les gens dans
une position désespérée il se passe des
bêtises et voilà
s'il vous plaît une raison
est-ce que je pourrais lire un document
s'il vous plaît
non je vous ai demandé un papillon
à quel moment on a pas le droit
de tous les diables
chantez juste ou chanter faux je m'en
fiche je préfère le rock à la musique
classique
nous avons fait cette manifestation pour
protester contre l'abondance des
voitures dans Paris tant au point de vue
circulation pollution par le bruit que
par les gaz d'échappement
en tout cas il y en a qui n'ont pas
perdu de temps pour exploiter le filon
comme cette marque suédoise regardez qui
a posté ça sur les réseaux sociaux
commande surtout c'est la régularisation
des de la circulation dans Paris la
misère des vélos et les vélos
communautaires mais en fait ils avaient
déjà inventé les pistes cyclables et les
vélibres
je crois que je
je pense surtout ce que je dis peut-être
je dis un petit peu plus que les autres
mais si je disais tout ce que je pense
imaginez un peu